(provocative music)
- Hi, Bill Mobley for
The Brain Channel again,
and, really happy today to be talking
about a topic that I think
bears a lot of careful consideration.
It's a topic that relates
to cognitive decline
in an aging part of our population
that's not as well
featured as it should be,
and that's the Latino community.
At UCSD we're really making
efforts to do a great job
in understanding more
about cognitive decline
with aging in Latinos.
And we're doing more than that.
We're trying to prepare for a future
in which we have young investigators
who are really highly-skilled
in carrying out such studies.
So I'm today with Alison Moore,
who is professor of medicine
and chief of geriatrics and gerontology,
Hector González, who's associate
professor of neurosciences,
a brand new faculty member
who's done terrific work in this domain,
and then, Maria Marquine,
who's assistant professor of psychiatry.
And we'll talk with all of them.
But I thought maybe I'd start with Hector.
Tell us a little bit about you,
about what you've been doing,
and about your passion for this topic.
- Well thanks, Bill.
I am a neuropsychologist by training
and I've been in this
work for a long time.
I actually will say that I've been
studying Latino health
and aging all of my life.
It's something very
important to me personally,
but also it's very
important for my family,
and my loved ones and my community.
So, I feel very strongly
about the topic of
health among my community.
I think what you said is really important,
that, here we are in California,
the largest state in the Union,
with a 40% population that's Latino.
And, as you also said, that
we really don't know that much
about the health and
aging of this population,
especially with regards to
Alzheimer's disease and research
or and other dementias.
We've been very successful
with getting large studies supported
by the National Institute of Health.
The problem is, though,
that we just have not
been able to attract
high-caliber scholars.
You mentioned that I came early,
or recently here to San Diego
and I'm delighted to be here.
And I think it's wonderful
that UCTV's picking up this story,
because it's such an
important topic to the state
and also to the nation.
And I think things have
changed since I was here
a couple decades ago.
So, with that in mind,
this is a wonderful place.
It's nice to see that attention focused
on Latino Alzheimer's dementias.
And, this is a fantastic place.
The problem has been that we just
don't have enough scientists in the field.
We have a underrepresentation
of Latino, Latina,
research scientists, professors,
scholars in the field.
And this is the beauty of this
project we'll talk about here
is that this is a direct mechanism
how to build up the scientific workforce
in a population that's understudied.
And there's great need
to understand dementias
in this population.
- Hector, let me ask a
little bit more about
the project and about your passion.
My recollection is that
the percent of those people
who are involved in studies in AD
that are Latino is tiny.
And so, is one of the ideas that,
if you have folks that are
trained in this domain,
and specifically folks that are diverse
and specifically folks that
are Latino, that those numbers,
that participation in the
community, might increase?
- I hope so.
This has been my passion
throughout my professional career.
So I've dedicated my life to this work.
And I think that that
should or would be the case
with other Latino scholars, scientists,
that because of that relationship,
that passion to understand and help,
which is very endemic in our population,
that that kind of synergy,
if we can create that kind of
synergy, that kinda workforce,
then I think we would be able to
make a big dent on that problem
of the dearth of underrepresented
minority scholars
or scholars interested in
Latino health and aging.
- In other words, how can we really
understand the problems they have
unless they're part of our team,
essentially part of what we do,
the sort of folks that
interact with us daily
to really ferret out
these research questions?
I guess that's part of it.
- That's part of it and I think, too,
is that it's been my experience in
that, having grown up
a minority in the U.S.,
having grown up in southern California,
has given me insight into what it's like
to grow up as a minority.
And I think these are
some fundamental questions
that come up in the research
and that I've used in the research,
to help study the problem
and look for solutions.
So I think it's that built-in insight
that is really a key ingredient
and what I see as a valuable resource
in recruiting, retaining and promoting
diverse scholars in the
scientific workforce.
- That's great.
Alison, tell us about you,
about how you got here
and about your interests.
- Thank you Bill.
I'm, too, grateful to be
here in this important topic.
I came here not very long
before Hector, actually.
I was really pleased to be,
and really thrilled to be
part of this center and
we got the idea for the center,
it came out as a request for applications
in standard NIH way.
And this was a version of
the center Hector and I
had both been part of in
our former institutions,
Hector at Michigan, me at UCLA.
And it was a center always with the idea
that they wanted to identify and train
underrepresented minority scientists
to do work focused on minority aging.
In this new version of
it, they wanted to focus
specifically on Alzheimer's
and related dementias.
So when I got here, I'd had the experience
of being part of one of these centers
and knew that UCSD was a super
powerhouse in neurosciences,
and I'd met a few of
the people in the ADRC.
So, I thought, why not try
to write a center grant here?
So, I'd had the experience of, again,
being part of the center
at my former location
and, with the support of a
lot of the people in the ADRC,
and Jim and Hector and being
inspired by Latino scientists
like Hector and Maria, I really
wanted to work with them,
collaborate with them,
to put this together.
We also partnered with
San Diego State University
because they are a
Hispanic-serving institution
and UCSD hasn't had quite the history
of minority engagement, I'm gonna say,
as has that institution.
I also knew from my prior
work with Rick Morris
that would make it a stronger center.
So we did that.
We've partnered with
SDSU and were successful
in getting this application together.
And so, we were funded
and started the center
just in the last several months.
It's been our first year
still figuring it out,
but it's gonna be great.
The idea is to train
three investigators a year
from different places.
It doesn't have to be
just to SDSC or UCSD.
It can be other places,
ideally in the area.
And they get funded for
a year to do a project
focused on Alzheimer's
and related dementias
in minority populations.
The focus of our centers,
Hector has said, is Latino dementia.
We train them and the idea is really
to help them be successes
in their academic careers.
They get hands-on training
and Maria can talk about that a bit more.
She's experiencing it. (laughing)
But we really, again,
that's the whole point
is to create a new
generation of investigators
who can carry on this important work.
- Terrific.
What challenges do you see in
the success for this program?
- Number one, I would say is pipeline.
Do we have enough people
who are underrepresented
minority scientists
who can participate in this program?
At my last institution,
this program had been
around for about 15 years
and that became a challenge
to find enough people who
really were honestly
underrepresented minority candidates
to be part of it.
So I perceive that could be a challenge.
Again, we're in our first year.
We still have a pretty
new, very new thing.
So we'll see.
So that could be a challenge.
I know UCSD is really working hard
to diversify its scholarly workforce.
So I hope that helps us.
I think that's gonna probably
be the biggest challenge,
is actually getting enough
people to participate.
- My sense is that it's a more
general challenge to attract
such folks into science,
medicine and science,
and that, probably,
visibility in the community,
sort of indicating to kids
who are in grade school
or even in high school, hey
you could be a scientist
studying really an important problem.
Probably it starts there.
My guess is that the pipeline
gets bigger as you go younger
to try to bring people
along to feel that they,
yeah, they too, could be just
like you when they grow up.
(Alison chuckling)
Right?
Good.
And here is Maria, who is
beginning this process.
Tell us a little bit about
you and your background,
but also what kinds of
things you wanna do now
under this program, Maria.
- Let me see where to start.
I came to the U.S., or I moved to the U.S.
about 20 years ago now.
And I also trained as a
clinical neuropsychologist.
I first went the clinical route.
So I was first primarily a clinician
and seeing patients in clinic.
Being that I'm from Uruguay
originally, I'm bilingual.
I speak Spanish and English
fluently, hopefully.
(all laughing)
Sometimes I think
I don't speak either one well.
But, I try my best.
Working as a clinician,
was that I really started to understand
the need for science in our community.
I experienced it firsthand,
seeing patients come through
the door and I was trying to do
clinical neuropsychological
evaluations and diagnosis,
and it was very hard to do
because we didn't have
the tools to do that.
We were forced to use, not forced,
because there were no available norms for,
especially for Spanish speakers
or English-speaking Hispanics,
which made it really hard
to make these diagnoses.
I had a number of people
come through my door,
that they had been diagnosed
with dementia 10 years prior
because the appropriate
norms had not been used.
And I evaluate them and I'm
like, you're doing pretty well.
It's just that a person
would come through my door
that had no education
and they were comparing the performance
with somebody with a
high school education.
And so, that opened my eyes
to how big of a need there was
in the community in
create these instruments
and in understand Latino cognition broadly
and in aging, particularly.
When I was doing clinical work,
I was at Rush University Medical Center
and I started collaborating in research
with the Rush Alzheimer's Center there.
And that's really what
made me want to move
to the research realm.
So, we then moved to
San Diego with my family
and I joined UCSD about six years ago.
And I saw the opportunity
to make the switch
to do science and do research,
and not only be at the
forefront of clinical care,
but creating the knowledge
that would help clinicians
and would help healthcare providers.
So, that's how I got into the field
of neuropsychology research
and Latino cognition in general and aging.
When I got here, I joined a fellowship
at the HIV Neurobehavioral
Research Program,
the Department of Psychiatry,
to do research in aging Latinos and HIV.
So that's much of what
I've done until now.
With the aging HIV population,
there's been an increased
interest in Alzheimer's disease
from that realm.
And I had my earlier experience
in Alzheimer's disease
when I was trying to do both the clinical
and the research work.
So that's kind of my background
and how I got where I am.
What really drives me to this
type of research is, again,
the understanding that it's very needed.
Personal as well.
I think most people have
been touched by Alzheimer's
one way or another and so,
that became very personal to me
when some family members were diagnosed.
And I wanna be part of
trying to find the answers.
In my research here at UCSD,
what I've been finding is that
the way that, sometimes, we try to
tackle and try to understand
what Alzheimer's disease is,
or what predicts Alzheimer's disease
or problems with cognition,
is not always the right one
because it's being looked at from one lens
of a specific ethnic or racial group,
and looking at factors that
might be predictive of problems,
looking it through this one lens.
But there's many different
ways to see the world,
and I think when you can see
it through the Latino lens,
is then you can start seeing
what might be important things
in that area and how can we
look at things differently
so that we can find answers
that help that population,
the Latino population,
but everybody as well.
- So you discovered a gap.
- Mm-hmm.
- So you were doing clinical
work and you discovered,
my goodness, people are coming to me
who've had a diagnosis of dementia
and they don't have dementia.
And, there was a gap there in being able
to actually deliver a tool, a test,
that could accurately say,
do they have dementia or not.
So, you saw that gap and then
you, basically, are
trying to fill that gap.
And there are actually
two gaps, aren't there?
One is the lack of
tools and understanding.
But the second is the gap between
wanting to do research and
knowing how to do research.
Because just because you're a clinician
doesn't mean you know how to do research.
So this program then helps
with both gaps, does it not?
- Absolutely, absolutely it does, it does.
I think the program is
providing an infrastructure
that I hadn't found before.
I think the didactics that
Alison was referring to earlier
have been fantastic.
I don't think there's
anything like it here at UCSD.
I've been searching for it
and there's nothing focused on that area.
And so I think that's been great.
I think the mentorship has been fantastic.
I think what really is the
best thing of all, though,
of having a center like this,
is kind of the, how do I put it,
like the feeling that like
somebody cares, you know?
Somebody thinks this is important.
- Yeah.
- Somebody thinks
this needs to be done.
And that's not always found.
I think, as I'm sure
Hector had this before,
had this experience before,
is that, coming from a
different background,
it sometimes can be a
little bit alienating
or a little bit kind of
like, how do I fit in?
And having that infrastructure,
I think gives that.
- Having people who understand,
not just that there's a problem, but that
it takes a sensitivity to this culture
to understand that problem fully.
- Mm-hmm, you put it beautifully, Bill.
- Oh no, thanks.
But it's just true for all
of us, isn't it really?
To me, it's not so much a,
We all have a culture.
There's always, for all
of us, there's a context
in which we've grown up
and live our lives and
it always feels a little bit frightening
when you go to a different context
and people don't quite
understand what you're saying and
you kinda look for friends.
You kinda look for people who kinda
know what you're saying when you say it.
And so, the fact that UCSD
can give that a happy home
is really a compliment to you guys
and to you as a beginner,
but to people who have been around,
understand the problems and are
making this a better
place for people to learn.
So Alison, here's Maria and
she's this great new learner
and so, how do we help
her at the next stage?
What comes next for people like Maria
who now wanna build their career?
Not just train, but build their career.
- We'll hook them up with
people like Hector (laughing)
who has a lot of grants and a lot of data
for her and others like Maria
to use and build their careers
with the papers and
write ancillary studies
and also mentorship to build careers
in different paths,
perhaps, different topics.
Mentorship is super
important in my experience.
So, you take great people,
you give them great training.
You have to have mentorship, I
think, every step of the way.
I still get mentorship from
many people in different topics.
So, you help them.
You support people
and that can make the difference I think.
- I think the mentoring
thing is really critical.
I mean, I agree with you.
I've had several really
terrific mentors and
I make the comment, you should
never let a good mentor go.
Stay in touch with them.
Call them, write them
and send them an email.
Get their input.
Because, the more they know about you,
the more they really can
sort of give you some advice
about your career direction.
So you're a mentor.
- Yes.
- And you'll
continue to mentor.
- One of my favorite
things to be and to do.
- Yeah, yeah that's great.
Hector, what about you
and your role in this
and what you'd like to see happen
here at UCSD more generally?
- Maria hit it on the head is that
that sense of community is here
and just to build it further.
I mean, it's a small community.
I'm fortunate to be also
at the Shiley-Marcos Alzheimer's
Disease Research Center
where we do have a strong focus
on Latino Alzheimer's disease.
And we have the support of
our good chair, Jim Brewer.
And feeling that you're welcomed here,
you're valued here and part of a community
is something we need to build further.
It's good now, but we
could make it better.
So that's, I think, the value
of this training program is,
it doesn't exist, so let's just build it.
There's no way we can just wait around
and it'll just come to us.
So, I think this is a great opportunity
to be able to build that community
and a strong community
too, because we have
such great science here at UCSD
and we really need to
take it to the next level,
and I think this is a
fantastic place to do it.
- So, Maria, look ahead 20 years,
and see yourself in the
context of the folks
that you'll be working with.
How will the world be different
for Latinos who are aging
as a result of the kind of
work that's being done here?
This is a dream of course.
This is a best case.
- I think best case scenario is,
there'll be very little of it.
So very few people with Alzheimer's.
We'll find a way that we
can prevent it or treat it.
If you ask me, that's my ideal--
- Good.
- world, where we can
find a way that it's
hardly happening anymore.
I think that's gonna be very tough.
So, if we, that cure
that has not been found,
I hope that we built enough
knowledge, enough understanding
to support not only the person
with Alzheimer's disease
that's Latino, but the families.
We always talk about,
Alzheimer's just doesn't touch one person,
it touches the family, especially
in the Latino community.
So I think I would like to see
that we have knowledge,
understanding and resources
to support those communities.
I think, sometimes, it's overseen
how much practical help is needed.
I think the knowledge is number one,
but practical help, resources,
in a community that might
have less resources,
less access to care, less
opportunity to buy into care,
that we can provide that for
everyone that might need it.
- And it's a great dream.
Of course everybody in the world
wants the dream of no
Alzheimer's to be true.
But I think it's especially
important that you guys
are doing the kind of work that makes sure
that Latinos benefit to the
same extent as non-Latinos
in those advances that will come,
and that, one day, we'll
all be able to say,
wow, Alzheimer's disease?
Yes, I remember that.
It used to be a problem, but
not anymore for any of us.
Thank you all for being here,
Alison and Hector and Maria.
Appreciate your being here and
the great work you're doing.
This is Bill Mobley for The Brain Channel.
(provocative music)